- Hi everybody.
Adam Metallo with the
Digitization Program Office,
at the Smithsonian.
It's under the office of the
Chief Information Officer there
and we work with all
the museums, archives,
libraries, galleries to increase
the quality and quantity
of digitization across the organization.
Specifically, my role is
to increase the impact
of said digitization.
So how do we get the maximum
mileage out of all the work
that we're putting into what we're doing,
and computer vision and machine learning
and things like this are one
of the most exciting ways
that I think that we
can show the potential
of our collection at scale,
and so this is definitely something
that merits a lot of attention and focus.
This is sort of two parts.
First I've been haunting
a lot of trade show,
industry conferences
over the past few months,
to see what other industries
are doing with the technology,
how they're thinking about it,
how far along one group is versus another.
So the Nvidia conference late last year,
they've convinced me that GPUs will solve
all of our problems,
but beyond the propaganda,
it's clear that this is having an effect
across all industries.
This is not something that's unique,
and we'll definitely
need to make sense of it
sooner or later,
and sooner's ideal in my mind.
I went to a conference run by AAM,
called Museums and New Intelligences.
The emphasis there was really
on in gallery experiences,
so imagine maybe a camera
tracking visitors' expressions,
and they may be happy or
sad or bored or excited,
and that's kind of a way to get a metric.
I think that's super interesting.
I also think that's something
that is going to be commoditized
by a lot of other industries,
and that's probably not the domain
that we need to worry too
much about making progress.
GSA Future Services Now was a
government centric conference.
The clear message there
was that across agencies,
they're thinking about this technology,
and they're aggregating there as well,
and so they're one major
set of stakeholders
that the Smithsonian and
anything cultural heritage
can look to to leverage our
data against government data.
National Academy of Sciences -
The Science of Deep Learning.
A lot of the scientists went
out of their way to say,
this is not a black box.
It's a very big complicated box,
and you don't know how it
works until you've built it,
and you've run it, and see how it breaks.
But there is recourse
when things go wrong,
and you can go back and see
how you need to tweak things,
and I think the real trick with this stuff
is the lack of transparency
that most industries have
in making models available,
and for us, I think one of our superpowers
that we can leverage here, is our ability
to be more transparent with these models,
and we could play a major role with ethics
and standard operating procedures
for how we use this technology.
Fantastic Futures was a conference put on
with Stanford University Libraries
and National Library of Norway,
and there, librarians are great.
They can adapt to anything and say,
"Yeah, that's stuff librarians do."
And they were pretty ready to say,
"Yeah, it really doesn't
make sense to strictly think
in terms of the libraries.
This is a scenario where
we're all stronger together
across disciplines."
Another really critical thing there was,
I heard a bit about
triangulating low quality,
low accuracy data to get
high quality of results.
And if you think about
our collections records,
when we get our collections
records perfect,
we put them out into the world,
and we're very proud of it.
When our collections
records are not perfect,
we hide them in shame
until we either retire,
or until we have time to get
around to making it perfect,
then we'll release it,
and I think that finding a way
to make this imperfect data visible
and something that we can compute against
to bootstrap the quality of our data
is a critical possibility.
It's a standard explainer
for machine learning versus
classical programming,
so this was useful for
me to wrap my head around
a really fundamental difference
between what we're doing here,
and I think this is the cultural change
that a lot of folks across the Smithsonian
are gonna need to wrap
their heads around as well.
You sort of switch the
equation a little bit.
I think the really interesting thing
is the possibility of bootstrapping,
and the fact that we do
have all the raw ingredients
with our data as it stands, flaws and all,
to get much better data
out of what we currently
have at our disposal.
Moving on to a workshop
and presentation series
that we did in a collaboration
with Google Arts and Culture,
and the Data Science
Lab with Rebecca Dikow.
Basically the goal here
was to introduce people
from across the Smithsonian
to general premises of machine learning
through a webcast and lecture series,
and then we also did a workshop
where we invited a bunch of people
from different disciplines
from across the Smithsonian
to think about how this
applies to their own work.
You can see the very credibly gentleman
on the left hand side there
with his hand gestures speaking (mumbles).
So very simply, the goals here
were to provide a basic
introduction to machine learning,
try to identify what our
common challenges are,
and then also to be very deliberate
about developing grounds
for collaboration,
very much like what
we're doing here today.
And I think what keeps me
excited about this stuff
is just this visualization,
and defining what this long tail
of our cultural heritage collections are,
if we can do that, and the more
specifically we can do that,
I think the more important we become,
not just at getting good
at using these tools,
but at giving back to the industry,
and playing a role in how
AI and machine learning
and machine vision and every
variation of these terms
is affecting our world.
Tried to visualize this a
handful of different ways,
because nobody ever seems to think
that's as important as I do.
This is something I pulled
together on the train,
it's kind of lame.
I think this is more
compelling, but not as accurate.
So how did we go about
organizing this event?
We had approximately 50
different participants,
so on the left hand side here,
you can see representation
from different units.
Sometimes we had a couple
of people from a unit,
sometimes just one rep,
and basically we organized
them into different cohorts
with different themes.
Accessibility, American
Women's History Initiative,
Art, History, Culture,
Informatics and Metadata, Science,
Search and Discovery,
Transcription and Translation.
And as you can see by this next slide,
ooh, nope, I'll wait for that punchline.
We came up with about
65 independent concepts
that were derived,
and some of these were
one-offs, somebody said,
"Hey, this would be a great idea,"
write it down, that's a concept.
Other things that were brought
to the table were things
that folks had been thinking
about for months or years,
and wanna bring to the table
as a possible project to move forward.
And now you can see,
as we break down all
these individual concepts,
and try to find what the
relationship is between them,
we now have a tangled mess.
When we tried to thematically organize
what our interests were.
It no longer made sense,
and so the physical boundaries
of the walls of our museums,
as we make the digital transition,
are making less and less sense,
but I think that with this
wave of new technology,
they are going to make less
sense far more quickly,
and it's something that
we can prepare for.
Some of the critical strategic interests
were bias of course,
and understanding the bias
in our own collections.
This is something I feel
strongly is a risk, of course,
but it's a potential benefit
as much as it is a liability,
so I'll try to talk a
little bit more about that.
Data and training,
collections enhancement,
so that would be the idea of
bootstrapping our metadata
up into something higher
quality, higher accuracy.
Audience driven priorities,
things like enhanced search,
like we've seen examples of today as well.
We also can organize these ideas
into more tech-centric themes,
and again, it's a tangled mess of knots
where our traditional disciplines
no longer make as much sense,
and it also means a
tremendous opportunity for us
to be more efficient about how we develop.
So I'm gonna zoom in here to, specifically
the American Women's History Initiative
concepts that were developed,
and what we're looking at
here on the left hand side,
is the group of about four people
who are working on the American
Women's History cohort,
and if you track the purple lines on top
over to the right hand side,
those were the ideas
that they came up with.
Don't worry about reading
the fine print too much.
Down here we have other
cohorts that came up with ideas
that were strongly
related to or applicable
to American Women's History,
and so you can see those popping
up on the right hand side.
And then basically, what you have here
is a list of ideas that do the most good
for the most people
based on the interests
expressed at this workshop,
as opposed to what might be the project
represented on top,
which may have all the virtue
in the world in and of itself,
but does not offer as much
opportunity for us to build upon.
We're gonna track backwards now,
and see how else this
method might be useful.
At this layer we can see all
the key internal stakeholders,
so what units across the
Smithsonian are interested
in these particular concepts.
What was that individual origin concept
that got truncated into these
more overarching themes,
and essentially we have all the details
that are so difficult in getting traction
on a given project.
So this isn't an argument
to think beyond our grasp,
but it is an argument to
initiate and design projects
with lots of open doors for expansion,
and new opportunities when
we come to a conclusion
on these collaborations,
and I think that's what
this type of mindset might help with.
And I think the point here is that,
we can overlay any type of
content with this concept.
So these were a number
of different proposals
that stemmed, some from the workshop,
and some were ideas that
were in progress originally,
and that were proposed as
collaborations with Google,
but the exciting thing is that
we could take any other idea
and basically do an analysis
of how effective it would be
for our overarching goals,
and we can be pretty flexible
in terms of which content
we choose to run with in this respect.
And in terms of bias, and I
think the shackles example,
which is really important,
on one hand it's a huge liability
when we mislabel an object like that,
and it can be hugely damaging.
I don't want to underestimate
the severity of that as an issue,
but I also think that there is a flip side
and an opportunity there,
and in the end what happened
is that surfaced a deficiency
in the model that's being used,
and I think that's a really
critical role that we can play
and cultural heritage in general
with our data on the periphery
of what general tech
companies have access to,
we're really gonna be
the critical last mile
in making a lot of what
they wanna do possible.
So it's basically, I'm advocating for us
to value what we have to
offer the rest of industry,
as much as we're excited
about how we can use this tech in house.
And that's all I'll say.
- [Announcer] Thank you so much.
- Thanks.
(audience clapping)
(serene music)